and whiskey co-founder and president of
23 me
partnerships I would always recommend a
partnership because for me it's a it
seemed like you know when Linda and I
first met we came together and said we
have no ego we really want we just want
to make this happen and we we worked at
an amazing schedule where you know I
tend to go to bed late Linda wakes up
really early so we actually worked
almost 24/7 for four years and and we
got an amazing amount of stuff done and
the contacts I had a tremendously
different number of contacts than Linda
had and we were really able to I think
get you know the kind of marketing reach
and the kind of you know publicity
because we came from different worlds
but had such similar ideas so it was you
know it's perfect it's it's it's really
it's to do a start-up when you only have
five people and and you need to you need
to you need to make such an impact and
especially with genetics personal
genetics there's so many people to talk
to so so I have to say we did a really
you know really proud of what we did it
was it was a lot of fun we had a really
great time and and I'm actually very
excited about the idea of working with
Linda and the Alzheimer's initiative
that she's taking on because I think
it's it's the culmination of exactly
what we've done and we both have
personal interests about what we want to
do and now 23 me has built this platform
to do you know consumer directed
research initiatives and and Linda's
executing on that and you know
Alzheimer's is gonna be her first
initiative she has other diseases that
she wants to go after and I think it's
to me it's it's a great moment the fact
that we you actually feel comfortable
left to leave and and say I'm gonna I'm
gonna you know take on my own personal
health issues that I really want to work
on in terms of being to women it's you
know I think neither of us really
thought about it that much we both
worked in industries where it's been you
know either
you know male-dominated or or or you
know so what makes you know it's the
questions come up and we never really
thought about it that much it's more
that people ask us about it a lot and
that there's conferences like the you
know unfortunate most powerful women's
conference like it's really fun but I
find that people then end up talking a
lot about like oh what's it like to be a
woman and to be honest for me the
biggest change was that there was
in the bathroom so but other but other
than that you know it was it was great
it was great when we had more people who
were all pregnant at the same time and
everyone was couldn't commiserate about
breastfeeding you know I could which I
guess is unique but it's it's you know
it's it's it we never really thought
about that much
I'd say 23
so as much as we have the reputation for
being the consumer oriented company and
we are consumer oriented were so heavy
on the science that to us it was it was
sort of obvious you know of course
you're gonna want your genetic
information we all want our genetic
information why would you not want a
Matic information and I think that
that's probably something that we we
underestimated in terms of the fact that
people don't really necessarily know
exactly why you know what what do they
want to do with them what do they want
to do with the genetic information why
would they want it and and creating you
know I think about other industries
where it's been a big technology shift
so something like TiVo TiVo was a big
shift in how people watch TV but
everyone understood the concept of TV no
one really understands the concept of
well why would I want my genetic
information and and I think one of the
other big challenges that we have is
that people healthcare is not a true and
just health care's on a true free market
because you are used to going to your
doctor and saying you want XY and z and
not paying for it and and so for that
reason us telling people why you can get
access to your genetic information it's
much cheaper than you know some of the
other ways you could get it and it's all
within your control that that's actually
a hard leap for a lot of people because
they're not used to paying for anything
for healthcare so it's one of the things
that we fact we've discovered that we
have to educate people a lot more about
you know preventive care why they should
actually invest in that and what are
things that they should do with the
information and the fact that they
actually are going to have to take a lot
more responsibility for for their health
and and that's a that's a pretty big
adjustment for people
I think those huge those huge questions
- to deal with it was funny early on in
the company we engaged with a number of
different bioethicists and we actually
talked about employing someone and then
we actually couldn't get anyone to join
because everyone found that this topic
was so interesting that they felt that
they this was going to be pivotal to
their academic career so so we've
engaged with a number of people we've
gotten them to you know always give us
feedback on it but fundamentally one
things we've realized it's an it's an
incredibly interesting area for the
ethics community to talk about you know
fundamentally what 23 Emmy believes is
that it's really about choice and if you
want to get access to something that is
fundamentally yours we believe it's your
right to get access to it it's not for
everyone that's abundantly clear to us
and those people should not have to do
it and so you know 23andme really wants
to encourage the debate we want to
encourage the debate we want to be a
participant in it we want to be
supportive of it and I think we've
remained very firm in that we believe
individuals should have the right to get
access to this information and how it's
going to be used and what are the right
what are the good things or what are the
bad things that society really needs to
have that debate and 23andme will be
there but it's society too should put
the limits on it
the Parkinson's initiative with Michael
J Fox and the Parkinson's Institute in
out here and we have individuals with
Parkinson's were given a discounted
version of the 23andme so we've designed
the 23andme site so that individuals can
get access to their data they can fill
out surveys specifically about
Parkinson's as well as about their
general health and they get all the
other access so information about their
ancestry they can connect and share with
individuals there's a community portion
they can learn from people so we want to
have a really engaging experience for
people so that we can keep getting
information from them so we have one
Parkinson's survey now we will plan to
have additional Parkinson's surveys
because the long-term goal is how do I
get information about you today but
let's say I want to know how does your
Parkinson's progress in 12 months in 24
months in 48 months because that
information will be really valuable to
correlate with your genetic information
so then comes in 23 and we on the back
end our researchers in house are
actually analyzing all the data so all
the information that we're collecting
through the surveys they then compare
with the genetic information and what
we're finding is we're actually making
really interesting discoveries so on all
the different questions that we're
asking about so we'll hope to announce
soon information about you know because
this Parkinson's community came together
what are some of the discoveries that we
have made and what are those discoveries
what kinds of discoveries will benefit
that community so that might also
integrate with a lot of the clinical
trials that are happening where clinical
trials are happening you know either on
drugs where we can potentially help
figure out why some people respond some
people don't respond what where there's
toxicity or there's not toxicity and
some of a lot of the Parkinson's
patients are eager to participate in
clinical trials so we might be able to
help make sure that they're they can
find a clinical trial that makes sense
for them
I think the biggest problem in clinical
trials is that they're underpowered and
that fundamentally that the studies are
just too small and they're designed in
such a way because they're so expensive
they're designed in such a way that
they're just there's a small cushion and
so you know they're expensive to run if
you need if you need a thousand patients
to really get the Clint the power that
you're looking for maybe you have 1,100
but what we're finding is that those
actually are still underpowered so the
advantage of 23andme that we can do is
we can actually have huge datasets where
we're not looking to collect you know a
hundred people with cancer or a thousand
people with you know multiple sclerosis
we want you know tens of thousands so
the Parkinson's initiative we've
announced you know we have over 3,000
people with Parkinson's in it which is
you know on a relative basis one of the
largest cohorts out there now so we're
looking to develop these large cohorts
and keep asking questions I think one of
the other advantages that we have is
that we can ask these Parkinson's
patients about their Parkinson's but
we're also learning about all these
other aspects of them so we asked the
general health survey and then we're
asking about commonly is drugs so you
know do they get a stomachache when they
take Advil how do they respond to
benadryl things like that so it's a
cohort where we can keep learning more
and more things from them I think we're
very focused on developing or
understanding the the relationship
between genetics and drug response and
so that could be either on the efficacy
side or the safety side but you know
there's it's a well-known studies that
have come out that said 50% of all drugs
that we take to have no effect on you so
what we would like to understand is if
you're given a drug is that going to
respond yes or no and is it going to be
safe yes or no and that's going to be a
critical mission of 23andme
to me it's very interesting that it's so
controversial the fact that it's it's
it's not deterministic because
throughout my life in medicine
I have never I've very rarely get a test
back that is so deterministic so you
know even when I was pregnant and and I
get a variety of tests back and they say
okay you're this is cutting your wrists
down for having a Down syndrome baby but
it's never it's never 100% unless I did
the amnio which I did not do so
you know I've in even things like
cholesterol if I if I if I find out I've
high cholesterol again that's a risk
base it means that I have a risk factor
for heart disease but it didn't tell me
anything specific it doesn't you know
some people even do very well with
having high cholesterol it doesn't say
specifically you are gonna die of heart
disease so in my opinion my you know
I've been very comfortable with having
diagnostic tests that that tell me that
I might be at higher risk or lower risk
based on some some information so for
the lerk to example that my husband has
he already knew that he had a family
history of Parkinson's disease and now
he knows that there is a genetic basis
for it and that he carries that genetic
basis for it so you know again he
already knew that there was the family
history he has it there and he has gone
through a lot of the literature one of
the things that he's found is that it's
not that well studied just yet because
it was a relatively recent discovery but
there is information there about things
you can do to prevent Parkinson's so
that could be changing your diet
exercising more and potentially drinking
coffee and those are all three things
that he does and and again going to the
critics all three of those things are
great for his health regardless so he
has lost weight he is much more vigilant
about you know eating vegetables and he
is trying to drink a little bit of
coffee so so I'm really you know I'm
really happy that we got that
information because even if it comes out
later that though he has other genes
that you know decreases risk and
therefore he's sort of at average risk
for Parkinson's
you know when I'm used to getting that
information and that kind of change in
in health care and to I'm happy because
he made a lifestyle change that
fundamentally made him healthier
the moral values that and the ethics
that that Google has definitely
influenced you know I think when Sergey
and Larry started the company they
really you know they were they were
right they weren't in it for the money
they started it because they really
wanted to create something that one they
wanted and two they thought was going to
change the world and and and I think
that that that really held up with 23 me
where we say all time you know we're not
we're not here just to be it would be
very easy for us to say oh we just want
to be another kind of diagnostic company
we come out with something very simple
we really want to change the landscape
you know every single day we want it we
want to take on the hard problems we
don't want to just you know find a
solution and make money and and and
leave it at that we really want to keep
evolving and take on those hard problems
so I think that Google's been really
inspiring in that way and that they keep
you know things like the the book
settlement like even you know all these
things that they're doing I'm I'm
continuously impressed by the challenges
that they take on and I hope that the
same thing happens for 23 me
the amount of information I think it's
we definitely are suffering from an
information overload but I believe that
there's going to be better and better
ways of organizing that information and
processing it so so that it's it will
enhance your daily life so even things
we were playing we have this having a
sort of once once a week I'll go through
on Google Earth and go sort of
essentially flying into a different city
and and we have this large monitor at
home and it's amazing resolution and and
I was in Tibet in 2000 and I could just
walk around the streets and and it's
things like that it's not you know that
it beat now that I have a small child
and I can't travel as much that's
phenomenally it's phenomenally
interesting for me it's fun and I think
that that's how information and
Technology just are gonna impact our
lives more and more on the personal and
on the fun side and more and more I
think also on on the serious I think on
the medical side I think we're gonna get
I'm really excited about radiology I
think I'm I've never seen there's a
there's a conference in Chicago every
every October and the stuff that's
happening in radiology is fascinating
and the stuff you can do with imaging
and I just think that technology and
information is it's overwhelming at the
moment but I think it's really going to
have a major it's really going to make
life better
to be honest and since being a new
mother than my my biggest concern
becomes is the health you know coming if
I was diagnosed with something you know
that was fatal in the next couple years
I can't imagine anything more terrifying
and so for me health health is we know a
lot about technology and we know a lot
about you know the world but I think
health is the one area where I find that
it's still it's there's so much data but
it's chaotic and and then it's still a
big black box so understanding really
what what's going to make me healthy and
what what's going to allow me to live
the longest life is definitely keeps me
up
I had a very unusual childhood and then
I grew up I grew up on Stanford campus
and I never moved and in almost all like
you know 80% of my kindergarten classes
all still friends and so I have to say
it's a lot of it'sit's the people on my
street who you know my next-door
neighbor is this guy George Danzig who's
who passed away a few years ago but he
was you know he was 90 and he sued
Stanford because he wanted to keep
teaching and you know he he had the same
beat-up car and and his house was
cluttered with books and stuff and he
would write me long letters about he was
actually really Internet except industry
and how that was the next big area but
people like that who were just so
interested in the world and and I have
to say I was lucky to live in an area
where I was surrounded by such great
people and and those people really made
me so you know it's a lot of local
heroes but but it's the people who
impacted me the most
the worst advice I probably ever got is
when I I was done with Wall Street in
2000 I took off here to travel I was
gonna go to med school and and I got a
job offer to go back to Wall Street and
and I kind of did it probably mostly
just I was like wow that's I can make
enough money to pay for med school it
will be easy and and everyone was really
supportive of that and and I think that
when you have you know Wall Street was
sort of at the height of the fame
everyone thought it was really cool and
I think doing taking that job was
probably the biggest miss doing
something doing something probably more
for the money was probably the worst
thing I think I've ever done
when I was investing in it and then I
would complain non-stop like I'm
investing in this industry that I feel
like is just churning out products that
are not going to nestle benefit us it
was actually Larry Page who who said you
know at one point he was so aired he's
like just stop cut if you're gonna keep
complaining just then go and do
something go and fix it
and and it was really I was like wow
yeah you're right like I should stop
complaining and I should just try to fix
it and and I think having that mentality
it's so easy to be in a work situation
where you complain and and fundamentally
it's it's your responsibility and if you
want to make that's it's the really fun
thing about starting the company if you
want to change this world this community
that we all live in then you know get up
and do it and and just start something
and if it fails you know every time we
get criticized I was like well that's
great that means I'm actually doing
something and I'm pushing buttons and so
every time there's something critical I
feel proud